hey everybody its Jessie and it's good
to be back I have a good weekend I hope
all you had a good weekend as well today
we're gonna start by going over a pull
request so I got a really big pull
request let me bring this over and y'all
can check this out it's you can see
there's a lot it's lot going on here
okay so this pull request 41 so if you
want to check it out the link to the
repo is in the description and I I went
over all of it this morning but I
haven't merged it yet because there's
there's a lot going on here and there
are some big decisions made so I thought
I'd like to give all of you an
opportunity to give me some feedback let
me know what your opinion is before we
merge it since it's such a significant
change to the project so just to give
you well I'll go over and let you see if
you can't bring this up on your own
computer right now I'll bring it up so
really appreciate this pull request that
definitely addresses a lot of things
some things that I had kind of realized
but just figured out I'll do that later
and there's some other things that I
didn't even realize yet like for
instance I had just done this I think on
Friday and didn't even notice that I was
getting this warning so I don't know
maybe at some point I probably would
have seen that but it's nice that this
was caught
so soon but so some of these are I think
may help with some errors that have been
reported or people are trying to run
this trying to you know clone the repo
and and start it up and they're getting
some errors so I think this this issue
here is probably where some of the
errors were coming from so I know I had
somebody recently on I think it was
Twitter messaged me about it
yes I think it was Nathaniel who's in
the in the live chat you know frequently
had a similar issue where basically I'll
show you since I have it up now so
basically was saying handle close isn't
defined so this seems like that would
fix it would fix that problem but here's
the so here's some of the things that
I'm not sure about and you know if you
have a chance to go through and let me
know what you think I'd really
appreciate that but it is it is a lot so
I'm gonna try to point out just a few of
the areas that I'm not sure about I
don't maybe understand fully and that
way it'll narrow it down a bit if you
don't really want to take the time to go
through all of it maybe if you could
just check out the few sections that I'm
not sure about that would be helpful and
one of the things I'm not sure about so
I'm I'm sure that this change will fix
some of those errors from from what I've
seen and what I've read about it after
I've done a bit of research to try to
figure out exactly what's what the issue
was so I know before in a lot of videos
before we've been using arrow functions
because it helps with this right inside
the the function so we get the right
value for this but evidently there are
some problems
with using arrow functions as well that
I was not aware of so I'll show you I
just did something so the new way so
basically and you can see how so the
pull request is from Matt right so you
can see how Matt redid everything to
this way but I just wanted to understand
it myself so I was already adding this
hover effect and I figured well okay
well normally I would do this with arrow
functions but I'm gonna try it this
other way so basically we bind this
inside this constructor and then instead
of using arrow functions here we just
use normal functions and then we call it
you know normally down here so I am
checking for a prop because I don't want
the hover effect to be the default but
basically it's just this onmouseout or
onmouseover alright see I mean you can
get the you get the point let me make it
a bit bigger just in case you can't you
can't see so I mean if you've been
following these videos or you use react
on your own you could probably see
what's going on here the alternative
being so right now in side nav right
we're not binding this in the
constructor we're just going handle
clothes for we're putting in putting
this in the Aero function I mean we're
still calling it down here the the same
way right so that's one of the things
I'm just I'm not sure about what are the
pros and cons of each I mean the the
very the obvious thing is that this is a
shorter way of doing things obviously
especially you start to get more of
these you know can really add up
so aside from from this being the
shorter way you know look is there some
way I guess what I'm wondering is is
there some way to keep this okay just
like this the nice
you know just one line really easy but
then still avoid any errors that might
arise from this so like the air that
Nathaniel was having in particular where
it it won't load the page for him and
keep saying that it's not found so
that's the one thing I'm a little bit
I'm unsure about I try to do some
research but just really didn't find a
definitive answer so I'm I'm fine with
doing it like this but I kind of want to
get I want to get to the bottom of the
issue and figure out like is there one
way that is recognized as the best
practice I know sometimes that there's
there's not a way so that's I mean
that's just how it is sometimes there's
it's debated and I'm okay if it's
debatable then I'm fine with going this
way because I'd rather you know add
another line or two and make sure that
there are no errors that's that's fine
with me but I thought this would just be
a good time to to see all right how
should we really be doing this so that's
one issue the other issue that I wasn't
sure about let's see
I guess there's two more I wasn't sure
about so this is so Matt's adjusted the
components to initialize state in the
class constructor so we are using the
constructor here we're using the
constructor here but I know in other
components were not let me try to find
one where we're not inside
I guess we are in a lot of them so maybe
I don't have one that I'm using that's
easy to find oh here we go alright so
here's the example so instead of doing
this where I've just set state very
simply instead using the constructor and
using this set state so from what I
understand and what I've seen in the
pool request everywhere that I've done
this has now been changed to use the
constructor is that what I should be
doing and this this really is not so
much me like calling into question the
pool request or doubting that at all
because I think it's really solid and it
definitely shows like Matt knows what
he's doing and he did take the time you
know to explain and not even just in the
pool request but in comments to previous
videos and things so this is more for my
understanding of how have I been doing
it wrong should I be doing it better I
mean I want to do it better you know for
myself because I want to do good work
but also if I'm going to be putting this
stuff on YouTube I don't want to mislead
anyone into doing the wrong thing so
that's another thing I'm just I'm not
sure about I had been using this and
it's been working right I haven't been
getting any errors but maybe there's
some there's some problem with this that
I'm not aware of and I should be doing
this all the time instead of this so
that's number two number three is
there's not really going to be any
demonstration I just just need to say it
so matt has ejected create react app so
if you remember I don't know one of the
the first few videos that we did for
this project we actually tried to eject
it so we did it we made a whole nother
project folder in clone
this project into that folder we ejected
and then we compared side-by-side the
the structure of the folders right so
the reason that he ejected has to do
with the sass files so he I guess and
this is where like his his abilities
definitely go beyond my own in terms of
setting up web pack because I'm not
really that great with web pack so I'm
definitely going by his explanation
because I've never done this with web
pack but it seems like what's going on
is that the Styles can be so like
there's no more CSS files when we're in
development and the sass it's just sass
files so I mean I guess that's cool
saying basically that when you go to
build then they'll be CSS files but not
during the dev process which should
speed things up also the the way the
sass files are set up is is different so
let me show you and of course you know
this is all available you can check this
out or on your own but everything's set
up like this now and you can see there's
some comments for explaining how to
import files and so I guess I would I
wouldn't have to import any more into my
components I could just use it all so
this part I'm not gonna lie I'm I'm not
exactly sure how this is gonna work just
from reading this I'm sure if I tried to
use it you know I catch on but anyway as
you can see this is a really big pull
request a lot of stuff has changed so
definitely didn't want to just merge
this in and say hey everybody hope you
had a nice weekend everything's changed
so that said there's definitely some
good thing I think
some good things in here and then
there's some things that I'm just not
sure about and it might be just because
of my inexperience so I'm gonna leave it
all to you let me know I don't think I'm
gonna make a decision on this yet I
think I'm gonna you all can let me know
what you think in the live chat we're
gonna do some code on on some other
components so I'm just gonna jump right
into what I was working on I just said
my Pomodoro cycle and right when I
started so this is kind of nice because
this has been my little break in between
we'll go right back into another one and
start coding and that'll give you all a
chance if you want to to check out the
the pool request on github and then
maybe later on either in one of the
breaks between coding sessions or at the
end then maybe we could try to come to
some sort of consensus and that might
not be a bad idea in case of people that
can't watch until later they can still
have a chance to join in so I will take
a look at what's going on in the live
chat since I started and then then I'm
gonna start my timer and and get to work
we're gonna be working on that generic
card component I'll show you I already
showed you how may the hover effect so I
don't really need to go over that again
but I would like to show you what I've
done so far and making them I would like
to have the option to make them links
like the entire card be a link that you
could click on I know that's not the
normal I mean normally with material
design you have little buttons at the
bottom and you click those but I think
yeah I'm pretty sure I've seen in apps
like mobile apps Google Apps where you
can click and the entire card is a link
I'm thinking in particular the news so
it still might be within the parameters
material design but you'll see what I if
you don't order to get what I'm saying
then you you'll see in a minute I had
someone in here at a few hours ago
giving a bunch of emojis and things so
that was kind of funny to see that but
no one no one was in there and I didn't
really see it until the person already
left so let's see aside from that let's
see
both are correct okay
hey everybody I see people were saying
hi
okay all right I'm getting some good
feedback already basically just to sum
up just for time it seems that the way
that we have been doing things is
allowed with the es es2016 syntax okay
so some of the newer JavaScript syntax
allows what we have been doing and so
some of the stuff I guess that's in this
pull request works as well but it's an
older way of doing things so okay well
at least I know I haven't been
misleading people and doing the wrong
thing I still really do want to know if
I guess what with the what the error was
coming from and how do I avoid that
using the new syntax
okay all right I'm going to so far a
really good feedback thank you I'm gonna
keep thinking about this as well while
we're doing the other stuff because to
be honest with you like I really I
really appreciate all the effort that
this took that Matt put into this so I
almost kind of wish it were split up a
bit into different pool requests you
know because then I could pull in just
the things that I know I want for sure
and then have a little bit more time to
think about the other stuff
so I don't know if Matt's watching or
not and I'd really I'd hate to ask him
to redo it and split it up because he
put so much work into it but we'll see
well I don't want to decide yet it will
give it will give it a little bit of
time to think about it
okay so let me show you I'm gonna pull
this over to the side for now let me
show you what I've been working on so
here's the the nice hover so now if you
do want to add a hover to any time
you're using the generic card component
and I mean this is in my project or if
you clone this project and you want to
use it to start so I know there are some
people that have cloned this project in
the previous project and are just
modifying it and using it as the basis
for another project which i think is
really really cool I've gotten to see
some some of you have sent me links
either to a live demo or the repo and
I've been able to like clone it and run
it and it's really really cool seeing
how you modified what I've done made it
better adapted it so anyway if anybody's
going that and you haven't told me about
it I definitely want to know because I
think it's really cool but anyway in let
me show you how to use this
okay so right now I'm using the generic
art component in posters j/s so I have
put in the actual content that is that
it's supposed to be in there got rid of
all the lorem ipsum and now if you add
hover Abul to the generic art component
you get that that hover effect which
material UI has built in this depth or
it's the z-depth but it's on the paper
elements you can't use it on the card
you have to use it on paper so I had to
wrap this in paper and the only thing I
had to do I don't think I had to change
anything else yeah everything else I
think stayed the same yeah because we
had bound the styles to get some of the
other things working like our flexbox
stuff too whatever the the div is that's
an immediate child of our other div so
like our container did
here this column so when we switched it
off for paper when all this gets
converted to just plain HTML it's still
just a div so since we set up our Styles
like that it was actually kind of nice
had we added the style directly to the
card in some other way or you know with
a class it actually would have been more
work so I didn't do that on purpose
but it ended up being working out well
we did have to get rid of the Box shadow
on the card because we were having a
double box shadow so that's kind of the
only thing we had to we had to change
from the default behavior of the card
but otherwise that's working well so
what I'm what I'm using now is okay I
just got Sebastian just popped into
Instagram and sent me a message so all
right I got a Sebastian cool thank you
so what I'm trying to do now is make it
so that these can be links so I'd like
for users obviously when it when they
get that little hover effect that should
immediately say this is clickable right
that's why I'm adding the the hover
effect also obviously the cursor changes
so I want this to be a link and you can
see I've already it I've already done
that here it's linking out somewhere
this is also linking this one uses a
regular just a tag and then this one is
using the react route or link component
but here's the problem that I just
noticed literally two minutes before I
started this stream I thought like hey I
got this I'm gonna be able to commit
this before the stream and then I
noticed this our flexbox stuff that was
giving us a uniform height for all of
our cards is not working which I kind of
anticipated but I was a part of me was
hoping it would just work I did think it
would might not work
let's see so that's that's basically our
first challenge and I just remember that
I forgot to set my Pomodoro timer so I'm
setting it now and I'll bring it over
here CEO can see yes so that's our
challenge we want it to be a link but we
also want the Flex bug stuff to still
work so here's what I'm thinking
I'm thinking that I'll move instead of
wrapping things in a link here which
honestly kind of makes it a bit more
messy why not make it an option within
the component so that I can pass a prop
saying you know it's like probably I
could just pass the prop giving the URL
and then if that URL is there then it
will use the link if not it won't be a
link so my first attempt at a twitch
I've I've since gotten rid of because it
didn't work was I I tried to put in like
within JavaScript in here in a ternary
just to put a beginning link tag and
then put the closing a tag down here
that didn't work so I never really tried
it before but I got an error when it got
to the the a tag that was just the
closing one so the slash a and I got an
error there so I guess it just it can't
handle I guess having the tags within
JavaScript dependent on you know whether
or not in this case we have a URL so the
other option I'd rather not do this but
the other option would be just to
completely copy this and have a version
that would use that would have the link
in there I'd rather not do that I
actually I just thought of another
option that might be better I could take
all of this
card stuff and make it a constant and
then at least I wouldn't have to copy
all of this so not really sure maybe
there's another maybe there's another
way to do this so I'm gonna check let's
see I'm gonna check the live chat just
really quickly just in case anyone has
pointed something obvious out that I'm
missing
and someone with the the tag lol lol
which I've seen before which I'm not
sure if it's if it's meaning to be laugh
out loud laugh out loud or not but
they're saying some really like
depressing stuff and that's live chat
which I'm not going to share because he
wants to be depressed but it's like
ironic right because they're they're
tagged on YouTube oh well anyway I
thought it was ironic all right so let's
do this
tyronn says can you put your cards in a
div and then call display flex well I I
could so I I kind of thought of that too
like okay well what if I just put a div
around here like a container div but
then I thought okay well that's just
going to be another level of divs that I
have here that's just going to kind of
make this a little bit more messy so I
think I kind of want to put I do want to
have this option in the component itself
and that was kind of the whole point of
this component was we wanted to have one
component that could do anything you
would want to do with a card
you just had to pass in the right props
so that was the idea I'm actually not
sure like was that a good idea I don't
know I think it's useful in terms of
performance
I don't really know enough to know
whether or not this is more performant
than doing it the normal way with
materiai and importing all the different
parts of the card but this is kind of
like a really simple react app I don't
think we're gonna have to optimize for
performance like a lot we're not I don't
know sometimes projects that are really
simple it's just not worth it to try to
think about stuff like that early on you
know just get it done and then go from
there
all right so let's some first things
first I want to test it out and just
make sure what I'm trying to do is going
to work so I am actually just gonna copy
all of this stuff and just see if it
works and then we can work on
refactoring it to make it hopefully a
lot smaller so this is going to be our
normal let's go let me get rid of that
space and we'll need we can keep paper
as the element that's around at all and
we're gonna copy this
now let's see we want to check for I
think I'll have two different option
because we're gonna end up either using
an a tag or a length tag depending on
whether it's an external link or an
internal link so I'm gonna need to check
yeah I'll need to check for that as well
so we'll have to pass that in as a prop
so they'll actually be two different
props that will get passed in it'll
either be for an external link I think
we'll call it URL and then those you
could just put the URL in for an
internal link we'll call it let's call
it link I guess we could I guess we call
it internal link an external link that
might be better okay that would be more
descriptive and obvious so in turn
let's see if internal link mm no I just
let's see internal link or
Pixar Inc
No
all right I'm not gonna get complicated
first let's just see the do the first
thing if it's an internal link then we
want to whoops wrong thing there we go
send its own link we want to render this
with
with the a tag
all right so if if the internal link
prop is passed then it will be the href
for this a tag and
if it's not present then it's gonna
render what we had there already okay
alright I'm gonna say that I should make
sure don't get errors okay great now
there is yet and let's get rid of this
and we'll test out our internal internal
link equals [ __ ] if I stood ice yeah let
me grab that link address gonna put that
in there and now let's save it and it
should be the same great okay so it is
the same you can see that's that's
working and these other cards are not
links we hover over them and not links
great so that part is working okay
so I guess for the sake of anyone who's
not that familiar with reactor what
we're doing I'm not gonna be able to
explain everything that's going on but
let me try to explain a little bit so
what we've done here is basically like
in NFL's statement but it's with what's
called the the ternary operator so
basically when we see that question mark
and then : here that means if internal
link is is true so if it exists right if
it has a value then we're going to do
this this first thing else we're gonna
do this second thing okay that's what
we've done now this is really nice but
it's not going to be enough because we
want to do three things so we want to
check if there's an internal link or if
there is an external link
the reason being I'd like to use what we
need to use the link component actually
what would make this really easy and I
should just check this let's try this
right now here's here's my idea that
could just make this whole thing a lot
more simple if we use the link component
but we pass in this as the href will it
still navigate because I think so we're
doing that right here and if we inspect
it we can see that we're actually
getting an a tag and then this is the
href so I say that's worth a shot
because we'll be able to keep it really
simple just really simple ternary yeah
let's let's try that and in that case we
won't even have to have two different
props which I kind of didn't want
because that's one more thing that you
have to try to remember as a prop so we
can change the prop to just be linked
and let's change this to linked
and then our age link
and then this is going to be I believe
it's too I have I think I have
documentation for a crowd or open on my
other screen I do so our link is going
to be yes it is too and we need to
import this
so let's import have it up here yes I do
great so we can remove yeah we can get
rid of this here we're not going to use
it here anymore but we're going to use
it here so hopefully I hope you can see
and I'm sure a lot of you can already
appreciate this but by doing it this way
and including it in this component we
can use this component in a lot of
different places and not have to worry
about including you know these things
and wrapping things so we're simplifying
every single time this gets used now it
will be more simple to use already we
won't have to include things if we would
have continued with what we are doing
here and and wrapping this you know in
our posters j/s component and then we'd
also have to do the same thing in any
other component we had so it takes a
little bit more work at first not that
much more work but I think in the long
run it definitely helps alright so I'd
like to remove this okay should we put I
guess we are using is exact let's see
this exact true I just can I put it like
that and I was just thinking do I pass
in true as a string or do I pass in true
within JavaScript oh well I'm not
getting any errors like this and I'm
assume that there's type checking and
react router so I guess this works
actually not I just think about it I'm I
may be getting a warning
I just haven't looked at the console in
a while all right so now we're gonna
pass in what we had before
oops link is not defined yeah it is
defined now did I take it out yeah okay
and what did I call that I think the
slash
so there's actually a page for poster
videos that I completely forgot about
and I hadn't shown any of you so that's
one more page who have to work on
fortunately we should just be able to
copy exactly what we did in the tutorial
page and just use it I think there's
maybe four videos maybe five I don't
know no more than five videos that we'll
just put in a page this won't be
difficult alright and that I ever
changed this no let's change this oops
link alright let's make sure we've saved
everything let's see alright great no
errors so we have this one and this one
let's see so I can't click this because
I haven't actually made the page yet so
it's not gonna take nanny to the page
great so these are actually links they
work I guess I could click great the
only thing that I'm not doing now that
it might be nice to do is open the
external links in a new window I'm not
sure I don't know if that's gonna be a
huge deal that would be something that
would be nice I would say that's
something that it could be added like to
the list of things to do to finish this
up and really make it polish at the end
but I don't need to ship with that
feature I don't know let me know maybe
you disagree on that because I would
need then to check assuming that I don't
want people to have to put in another
prop I would probably have to check to
see if it's a full URL I guess that's
how I would do it to make to see if it's
HTTP or HTTPS
and that still wouldn't be a foolproof
check right somebody could enter in I
don't know I'm probably overthinking
this anyway basically I think that's
mission accomplished right we have our
our flex box stuff that's giving us the
same height for up for all our our cars
is working again our links are working
our hovers working so I think that's
good
let me check I'm going to check the live
chat really quick just to make sure I
didn't make any mistakes before I commit
this
oh cool Patrick had a good thought and
you had this you had this way before I
did Patrick so good job on that sorry I
didn't look over and see it but he said
I can check I can just use one prop URL
and then I can check if the value starts
with a slash and that's how I can
determine whether its internal or
external that's better I think that
would be more reasonable than checking
for HTTP or HTTPS yeah I like that idea
breakpoint said page not found is on the
github page not the previous code with
the es6 syntax github pages doesn't play
nicely with react router I believe and
could be the cause yes that's so
reacts the routing is a bit messed up
for the github pages thing
okay all right cool so it looks like
looks like I haven't I haven't messed
this up
too much so I do have some good ideas
for ways to improve it but in terms of
basically doing what we wanted to do at
this point I think I'm safe to commit
this and then possibly revisit it with
some of those improvements namely making
it basically setting target --blank
to make things open a new window if it's
an external link and then open in the
same window if it's an internal link
which is a pretty standard behavior that
users expect I think I know I'm a little
bit annoyed if I click a link an
external link and it doesn't open in a
new in a new tab so I don't know about
you but that's that's what I've come to
expect and I I like it that I like that
so let me let me make this bigger there
we go and let's check the status okay
and so we're just doing to get commits
we're adding at the same time and
putting our message in all at the same
time and let's see
should I call the ocean feeling okay I
think that's about right
all right great everything past it works
and I will push it up to github alright
awesome so now that is up on github and
two minutes actually I'm gonna I'm gonna
do my break right now because if you
remember I did forget to start my timer
so it's been longer than 25 minutes so I
don't want to start something new with
two minutes left anyway so we're gonna
do the short break I'm gonna take five
minutes I'm gonna try to catch up in the
live chat after that five minutes we're
gonna go back and do another 25 minute
session of coding after that we'll see
we might be finished at that point I do
want to make sure I get done in time to
go home and take my son to karate on
time today so it's not gonna be a super
long stream definitely like to keep it
under an hour and a half today so I
think if that's the goal then probably
just one more appointment or recession
will be all we'll be able to fit in I
just got a message that the stream
status is now bad so in terms of quality
let me know what it looks like for you
all I'm not sure why OBS which is the
the streaming software is telling me
that I still have good quality going
through so over 5,000 kilobits per
second so I'm not sure what's going on
there okay let's see I'm gonna scroll up
a bit so I don't miss anything
let's see I say it says I'm interested
in contributing to this project that's
awesome thank you yeah definitely check
out github check out the repo see where
you can contribute if you're if you
don't really know where you can
contribute let me know like send me a
message and I could maybe give you some
ideas of things that that could be done
so yeah but definitely I would I would
like it if you'd contribute umberto says
for all the dotnet developers out there
dotnet core 2 was just released a few
hours ago so that sounds cool I don't
really use dotnet often I see I did have
to work with net last week uh-huh just
for a bit I didn't really do much with
it I actually just walked into
somebody's office who was having trouble
with it and they just showed me what
they were trying to do that wouldn't
work and then it worked
so I I don't I didn't really do anything
but it worked so that was that's the
extent of my DUT and that experience
okay Alejandro says guys do you think an
IQ of 106 is good enough to be a
programmer let's see I'm sure you you
got some responses in the live chat my
response to that question is going to be
well first of all assuming that the IQ
assessment is accurate right because I'm
I don't know like if you get an official
IQ test I suppose like you could maybe
trust the accuracy of that although I
mean it depends on different factors
everybody some people just have a bad
day right so assuming it's not just one
of these online IQ tests it's not
official and that is really the IQ which
I'm a bit skeptical of but if it is then
I would say it's it's fine to be a
programmer I I guess I kind of think of
it in terms of mental capacity and IQ I
like to make an analogy to like physical
capability in sports right there are
definitely been instances where people
who aren't physically like really big
are able to let's I mean I'm from the
United States and I played football
which I you say American football
so I'm most familiar with that so I'm
gonna say that analogy of the sorry
because I know a lot of you are not from
the other states you might not be
familiar but basically if you're not
familiar with it
the bigger you are usually it's a lot
easier to play football if you're bigger
right so people who are bigger usually
don't have to work as hard to be good
but there are lots of examples of people
making it all the way to professional
football and they're not really that big
but they put in a lot of work so I think
it's possible to be a good developer
even with a lower IQ but you may have to
put in more work so I don't think that
there's like a cut-off of like a if your
IQs this don't even
no it's just just you got to work right
so it's Sammy with a nice boy like if
you're short and you want to play a
basketball well like you better really
work on your shooting because you're not
gonna be really close dunking the ball
or anything like that you're gonna be a
three-point shooter or something you
know I don't really know what sports you
all are into what metaphors would work
for you but I think that that works as
well with with mental capacity to a
certain extent so anyway and I'd say
this like I'll take somebody with a low
IQ that loves coding and has it really
like a desire to learn and a hunger for
learning I'll take that person over
somebody who's a genius and thinks they
know is ever they know everything and
doesn't really take the time to learn
learn new things right I mean that's I
don't know
that's my it's my opinion on it there
are other things other than just IQ that
go into being a good programmer so
anyway I took up all my time on one
question sorry about that but I don't I
thought it was a kind of an important
question
all right
okay one last thing I just saw Sebastian
said I just submitted a PR a pull
request adding react helmet make sure
everything is okay because I have some
issues when I pulled your new code okay
cool thank you Thank You Sebastian
actually that's really cool that you
added react helmet I'm assuming that
react helmet is with helmet J s right so
I'm going to check that
maybe it's Sun show you changed your
says document heading take some attacks
oh okay
anyway my other screen I just checked
react helmet because I was mistaken and
I thought that that was just using
helmet je s with react but it's not
oh okay is this the same thing that we
had on a previous project all right cool
I'll check out that PR thanks thanks
Sebastian if you're not familiar I was
thinking about helmet J s which is like
security for node apps so which I've
been thinking about including in this
project but I mean at this point I don't
really need it but before we actually
put it on a server I've been thinking
about including that if anyone has
experience with that I let me know did
do you like it have you worked with it
how easy or is it to work with is it
effective based on the documentation it
seems like it would be a good thing to
have and it wouldn't really take that
long to set up all right let's start the
Pomodoro timer for our second coding
session I'll come back to the live chat
at the end so don't worry if I didn't
get to your question yet I'm gonna go
back through everything at the end try
to get to all the questions all right so
we could can we do I'm trying to think
of something that would be interesting
to do that we haven't done
hmm actually let's let's link up this
video page let's actually create the
page and we'll add in some of the videos
and then we'll get to show how to add a
route with react router so that might be
kind of cool to do I know we did it
early on we added react router and did
that but I imagine there's probably some
people who just started watching who
maybe hadn't seen that early on so maybe
this will be useful ok so let's go over
just just show you what we were doing
with react router we can check out side
nav j/s and inside nav you can see we're
bringing in actually did we bring this
in no we have it all in smaller
components so we are we gonna have to
get sidebar item nav link this time
where did we put all our routes oh did
we leave our routes in I'm sorry we left
them an app there is all our routes
okay awesome okay so here's where we put
all of our routes we're gonna need
another route and I think what did I
mean post your videos so I think that's
what I put the name is so just to give
you kind of a review we're importing
browser router route and switch from
reactor outer dome okay so see we've
wrapped everything in browser router and
now we can just put we'll just copy and
paste to add another route and
those two videos
and it's going to be the component
poster videos which we haven't made yet
so let's make that and okay so in the
views folder that's where we're putting
all of our all of our views obviously
we're gonna want to put post their
videos j/s so we're gonna say touch
source views coaster touch is now we
have posted videos Jess
great so I am going to go to our videos
page oh wait it was tutorial that's what
we called it so I'm gonna go to a
tutorial page let's move it over here
and then riaf in this one there we go
and since these pages are going to be
pretty similar I'm just gonna copy
everything and paste it over here and I
am gonna be able to get rid of some of
this so we're not gonna need this
paragraph and
[Music]
we may not need so many divs since we
removed that paragraph you'll see
we're gonna need to change the name
okay so now we have this page we should
be able to navigate to it
let me alright we should we've taken out
the paragraph so we'll know what the
page what page we're going to whoops
supposed to videos is not defined should
be helps did we not
we do oh we did not pull it in so sorry
I forgot a step so let's let's back up a
bit if you remember we we copied this
route we put it down here I'm not even
gonna look at the live chat right now
cuz I'm sure you all caught that and now
we're trying to tell me but we did not
import it so let's do that now and we're
going to import those two videos now
it's there we go it works now and if you
remember we already added the link with
the correct correct route so when we
click this we should go to that page
great and there we go so we have
basically the same content as our
tutorial page except we've removed the
text all right so what we want to do
then I don't think I've shown you the
page that that actually has the videos
so let me show it to you
and I had I think I mentioned earlier
but I had actually forgotten that this
page even existed
and so I happened to click on that link
okay so here's the page and so we just
have video videos for tutorials for each
one of each one of these things and okay
so right now we have them all in one
card I'm not sure if I like that I think
I'd rather have them be multiple cards
so each one would be well not not
exactly a card right it's just going to
be a video with with a box shadow so
let's try to do it like that and I know
we have labels yeah so we'll add this I
think maybe we'll put this as an h2 at
the top and then these can be h threes
below I have been kind of going with a
left align style for for everything so
I'm switching from the center line to
the left align I'm not a hundred percent
sure about it but we'll see how it looks
it won't be too hard to go back through
and and Center everything if later on we
decide that it it looks better centered
okay but for now we're gonna one two
three four okay so we need four videos
so let's let's copy some of this so the
first thing I want to do is put in our
headers so I can just copy the at our h3
component along with everything else
just go back to poster videos let's see
where we can put this that makes sense
that looks
looks good so actually since we did have
this this paragraph down here that
seemed to work and it was within this
container div let's try it there so we
would say h3 yeah we're gonna an h3 and
that first video was PowerPoint right
let's see how that looks okay that's not
bad it's really some bit small so I've
noticed something a little bit odd
so my all of my H tags were looking
really small way smaller than they
normally would be with let's say like a
materialized framework which we had used
before so what I what I had done so I
noticed on one page the H tags were not
small they were much bigger and the
normal size that I would expect them to
be I think it was an h2 and on another
page it was really small so I checked
them out and the only difference was
that on one page the a stag was within a
component that had a class of flow text
so I tried adding the flow test class to
the one that was smaller and it made it
look bigger
I actually I looked through what was
happening in dev tools with which CSS
was getting applied and it it looked
weird in that nothing from the flow text
was actually being applied it was all
crossed out
you know how things look crossed out on
dev tools if it's not in use so it was
all crossed out but it had a very
obvious effect so not really sure what's
going on there maybe it's just some type
of bug with dev tools that it's it's
crossing it out when it shouldn't be
anyway I'm not that worried about it
because it works like that so I'll show
you the difference you see how that
that's much bigger than it was so I'm
just gonna have to remember to put flow
text on everything which I don't mind
flow text even on H tags because it does
shrink them down on smaller screen sizes
if you're not familiar we imported we
brought over the flow text classes from
materialise which is a material design
framework similar to bootstrap but with
material
design so material you I didn't have
something like that at least I I'm not
aware that they have something like that
but it's basically make it makes your
font responsive so depending on the
width of the screen your font is a
different size okay so actually I like
that I think that that looks okay so
let's copy this and we should be able to
just copy this container right yes I
think so I think I want to keep it all
within this wrapper because we have some
vertical alignment going on here it
won't really matter that much because
this is always gonna be taller than the
screen but just so that I don't really
have to mess with that let's keep
everything within that container okay so
this should just give us an idea whoops
not what we wanted at all
so is that probably because of the Flex
that we're using so we could probably
fix this with just with flexbox stuff so
let's give that a shot before I get
changing the mark-up yeah that's got to
be something with flex because we're
giving it a width 100% all right so
let's see the line rather yeah
all right so let me see in the live chat
who is okay breakpoint just asked about
the Instagram the Instagram live feed
only they only let you do live stream
for an hour so I usually just let it go
for an hour and then turn it off I don't
I don't try to restart it so I sorry you
missed the live stream on Instagram but
it's only there for an hour okay oh you
know what actually I have a guide to
flexbox up on my other screen that I
never closed out from Friday Oh Patrick
city's never been able to find the
Instagram feed I'm not really sure the
inst I think if you would do if you
would search for my Instagram name which
I don't remember what it is but it's in
the description it should come up as one
of the top ones right I
I don't really search that much on
Instagram so I'm not I'm not entirely
sure but I think if you search the exact
name then it should come up okay
[Music]
all right so on my other screen I'm
looking at
some of the flexbox properties because I
can never remember which witchcraft via
switch alright let's try this
No okay what else I need to do
mmm
yeah okay so Berto says you can try it
try with of 100 VW because 100%
translates to 100% of the container
that's true
but it should so the container div is
much bigger so I'm thinking the problem
is with Flex something going on with
Flex box so let's take off I guess I can
I can test this out easily
where's my Flex deal and after there we
go see so if I take off flex see it's
working it's working fine which bad
maybe I'll just do that that seems like
a much easier solution let's just do
that there's we don't really need flex
box here there's no sense in vertically
aligning these because they're gonna
extend that they're much taller than
anyone's viewport is gonna be so let's
remove the v/line wrapper which will get
rid of the display flex
I great that works I make sure okay
this is behavior we want okay so
normally I wouldn't I wouldn't do it
like this so I would probably I guess
each one would be its own column with
the width of 100% but it looks like this
is all working out fine the only reason
I like to do it like that is
occasionally I've run into issues where
if I didn't keep the structure of like
container row column like the
materialized grid structure I would have
some on a small screen a very narrow
screen you could scroll horizontally and
there's this white space and I found
that if I always put everything within
that structure I don't have that problem
seems like I'm not really having that
problem here which is okay although I
guess I am this should work though
because it's not like I'm going outside
that structure everything is still
within the column so in this case I
think we'll be fine the problems that
I've had when I've tried to let's say
just put an H tag like right within the
container and not within a row and then
if it's a large amount of text and the
age tag then it it goes over but I think
we should be fine I do want to put an H
in h2
let's see where I can put this h2 that
would make the most sense maybe I can
put it in this
mmm I think I wanted yeah I think I can
do it like this
I can't remember with this page is
called poster video tutorials okay and
since we're not really gonna do that
that vertical-align i guess we don't
need this get rid of that and then we
can get rid of all of this and this and
we can now make this a stateless
functional component so let's do that
and we want to find another stateless
functional component so I can just copy
it
button
did I not make anything see the social
component I thought I at least had some
of them like that oh well you know I
have a lot of them in that pool request
which I put on my other screen
I guess copy and pasting only really
saves you time if you can find what you
want a copy
alright let's just just type it out
there it is
yes okay so what we want to do your
student side here for now
are we even yeah we're not even taking
any props right
all right see if I did that right
hey awesome I did
all right cool so I didn't really do a
great job of explaining what I was doing
so let me take a moment just to explain
so we had had in there a little bit of
JavaScript to check on the heights of
things and the heights of the header and
then deduct that from the height of our
container
okay that was to ensure that when we
vertically aligned something it actually
was look like it was vertically aligned
on the screen and it wasn't thrown off
because of the height of the container
also it was on on screens where the
content didn't take up the entire height
what was happening was our container was
extending down below even though there
was no content there so you would still
see the scrollbar you wouldn't see it on
a Mac but on Windows and Linux you would
see the scroll bar in the browser which
made you think you could scroll but you
could only scroll down a bit and there
was nothing there so I didn't really
want that so we had trying to queue it
added that in was it it may have been
Sebastian if it wasn't Sebastian and I
forgot who really did it I apologize but
we didn't need that right so well this
pages has enough content that that was
not necessary so we we took it out since
we took it out we didn't need state
anymore because you can see that was
using state to have this top coordinate
so we when we took out state then we no
longer needed to have this as a class we
could make it a stateless functional
component which is a little bit cleaner
you can see how we've we've done that
we're able to remove a line here two
lines here and then of course the few
lines down at the bottom where we have
all our closing brackets and parentheses
so I just cleaned it up a bit so
hopefully it's easier to follow with
a bit of explanation and let's see -
once I actually don't want this margin
bottom zero anymore that was also part
of trying to make sure that we don't
have this overflow that causes a
scrollbar so that yeah there we go that
added just a bit at the bottom which is
nice it actually could it could do with
a bit more here at the bottom I'm not
really gonna mess with it now I think
it's it looks fine
great okay so we have our actually see
this this is not really small again what
happened to our flow text
who
for some reason our float X is not
getting applied how how it was that's
odd cuz here this time it actually is
showing that floats X is getting applied
which is different than what it was
before but for some reason right like
this font size should be closer to 40
for an h2
hmm all right well I'm gonna have to
check that out later because our our
timer is up and I'm probably going to
depending on how long the question
answer session is I may finish this up
and commit this we'll see hopefully I
can I can get the right videos in here
at least and the right headers and yeah
that'll be good for the for the rest of
the day I'm gonna try to get this
finished for now I'm gonna go over to
the live chat I'm gonna answer the
questions if you're just here for the
coding that portion of the stream is
over
so if you need to de quit watching now
totally understand thank you for
watching and you know come back again
some other time I should be doing a
stream again tomorrow and mostly every
weekday around 2:00 p.m. Eastern Time
if you can stick around and you have any
questions please put them in the live
chat now if for some reason you can't
put them in the live chat or you can't
stick around to hear the answer you can
also send them to me on Twitter either
an or a tweet or a direct message or in
any other social media that you like I'm
pretty flexible whatever your favorite
is just find me on it and message me
there alright so I'm going to get to it
I'm scrolling back up to where we left
off the last time I checked the live
chat and I'm just going to go down
through and try to get get to as many
questions as I can
all right see
okay kevin has a great idea so kevin
says we should do a contribute MD that
says the steps to prepare your
environment to work in the repo so
install get note clone the repo npm
install NPM start but very detailed
that's a really good idea so I've
actually I've thought before at various
times that I should do that because well
before I started doing the videos I
thought it'd be a good idea because I
would like to get some interns or
student workers in here I'd really like
to help the computer science students to
get some real experience and some
projects for their portfolio but a lot
of them have no idea how to use git or
github or NPM or any of that stuff they
just they don't do that in any other
classes so anyway I think it's a great
idea and if I thought it would be useful
before this but now that you know we're
really working on these projects
together with all of you watching now
what makes even more sense to do that so
I will try I'm gonna put that on my
Trello board I'm gonna do that right now
so I don't forget that's also something
that if if any of you like writing out
like technical this would I guess be a
bit of documentation if you like doing
that then please feel free to to do that
that I imagine it would be the type of
thing that would be changed and made
better and more comprehensive as time
goes on so but to start with something
just very basic would be better than
nothing to help people out so anyway
I'll put it on my list to do if any of
you you're interested and want to get to
it before I get a chance to then that's
awesome so let's say I'm actually I'm
gonna copy and paste exactly what you
would you put in here Kevin cuz I don't
think I could put it any better than
that
understood
and I'm gonna give myself maybe like two
Pomodoro sessions and this is just to
get something there to start out with if
I was trying to make it really good I
would give myself more time but for now
just to get it started I don't want to
put a big number here and intimidate
myself and then I'll never do it
so anyways there I won't forget it by
the way if any of you want to check out
this Trello board that I'm using to kind
of keep track of this project the link
is in the description let's see so
anyway thanks Kevin
for mentioning that
okay let's see
okay cool it looks like refactored
genetic hard cool Patrick just linked
just about the the card server some
refactoring there which that's awesome
so check that up okay cool let me bring
this over
so anyway awesome thank you this is that
that card that we just made but cleaned
up so this is like I was saying to make
all this card stuff into a constant and
then that way and our actual you know
return here see how much more clean that
is right that's instead of having all of
this in there twice right now we just we
just have this really so much more clean
thank you
okay there's some stuff with so for the
Instagram profile let's say there's some
confusion so I'm looking at it on an
Android app so I don't know if the iOS
app is is very different but like when I
go to a profile if somebody has a live
stream or a recording of a live stream
up there's a little icon it looks like
the YouTube icon and a ring that's kind
of like red purple it changes colors a
bit around the users profile picture so
if you click that then you'll be able to
see it so there's no there's no text or
anything like that it's just that ring
around the around the profile that lets
you know that there's something to see
okay I just see Sebastian was saying
that I do not need the parentheses if
I'm just throwing the arrow function
right so let's see what time it is yeah
oh and that's since I'm not passing
anything in I don't need that oh cool so
I'm Bert Oh
actually I'm Berto asked does float X go
on the div as in float X h2 yeah that's
actually a good point let's try to put
flow text up up here oops and then I can
get rid of this completely let's see if
that makes a difference all right cool
great job Humberto catching that so
evidently flow text does not work if you
put it directly on the div which how did
it I thought it did something to that
age three maybe I'm just I don't know
maybe my lies are just being fooled
there and in doing let's see okay yeah I
guess not I actually kind of liked that
better when it was a smaller so like
this the font weight was lower but I can
change that later awesome okay so good
to keep in mind you can't use float X on
the h2 which is interesting I you can
use float X on P tag and it will work
but evidently in the H tag it does not
work cool
Joseph says hi Jesse just want to let
you know that I love to to hear you and
listen awesome
I'm glad glad you enjoy listening to the
stream thanks for saying that that
really means a lot to me so all the the
positive comments really mean a lot so I
actually recently I've had not a lot of
comments but a few comments basically
saying Jesse you talk too much just code
and don't talk so which my first
reaction is usually like just just now
which is kind of to laugh at it but
that's about like the extent of the
negative comments that I've gotten which
I feel really lucky about that but
anyway my point is like the positive
comments really really mean a lot and
they counteract any like somewhat
negative comments in terms of just my
morale and my desire to keep doing this
so anyway I really appreciate that thank
you
oh cool when I'm bear testers a hundred
percent agree with us his comment oh
thanks I'm bear to appreciate that
oh cool Patrick has submitted a pool
request for the gist that is it still up
here yeah yeah yeah awesome that's cool
actually I I was hoping that you would
do that because I mean obviously I could
have just copy and pasted this in but
then you wouldn't know if it wouldn't
have been credited to you it would have
been my commit so I'm glad that you're
gonna do that and then you know it'll be
on record for all time that you
submitted that and that was your work
and I liked it better like that that
you'll have credit for it
cool alright so I've gotten to the end
of the live chat which that's cool not
really a whole lot of questions today
which sometimes that happens not really
sure what what causes is sometimes we
just have like a never-ending list of
questions and sometimes it's it's almost
nothing but it's good today because I
didn't want to do a long stream anyway
so we're about it a little over an hour
and a half with the streams end up being
a decent decent length of stream anyway
so tomorrow I should be able to stream
at the same time I'm actually I'm gonna
check my calendar on my other screen
really quickly so I can give you a more
accurate let's see yeah I don't I don't
have anything on my schedule right now
so it should be 2:00 p.m. tomorrow I'll
put out a tweet about it and I'll try to
schedule it as early as I can tomorrow
morning
wait a second no tomorrow I'm not at
work sorry
I don't know what I was thinking
tomorrow I'm not working so tomorrow
there's no stream I'll be back on
Wednesday and it should be a normal
frame so one of the perks of working at
a Catholic University is that we get
extra holidays
there are these Catholic holy days that
we get off that no one else really gets
off so tomorrow I don't work because
it's the Feast of the Assumption so I
don't have to work tomorrow so that's
cool I'll get to hang out with my kids
but I won't get to hang out with all of
you which is a slight letdown for me but
I'll be back on Wednesday and oh I had
to add a few more things let me read the
last few comments here
Joseph says I think 10 positive comments
will erase one negative comment in your
memory yeah it's like that unfortunately
that seems like it is it seems like the
negative comments stick in your mind
more I really try to fight against that
though and stay positive about it so
hopefully my ratios a little bit better
than 10 to 1 but yeah that's that is how
it how it is so I really appreciate all
the positive comments and umberto says
wait tomorrow's a holy day of obligation
yes it is tomorrow is a holy day of
obligation these things too Tuesday I
don't really know it might depend on
your particular diocese and whether or
not they move it but since it's a
Tuesday I doubt it would get moved like
to the nearest Sunday so anyway so yeah
if you do happen to be Catholic
tomorrow's a holy day of obligation so
Catholics are supposed to attend Mass on
that day
but I think that's that's it that's all
I have so anyway and enjoy enjoy your
break from the livestream tomorrow
and I'll try to enjoy and have a good
time with my family as well and thank
you so much for all your help and all
your encouragement and the live chat
really appreciate that and I'll be back
Wednesday most likely same time 2 p.m.
Eastern thanks again and have a great
have a great two days